imagine heating a house like this speak
Hall in Liverpool is nearly 500 years
old inside its Victorian heating system
was expensive and difficult to control
so the National Trust which runs the
estate took a leap installing a ground
Source heat pump in a centuries-old
property this isn't a Cellar of the
dairy Courtyard and this is a what we
call the plant room and this is where
all the heart of the ground soil soup
Works this is where all the heat drawn
from the field is brought into
originally the house was heated by
liquid patrolling gas boiler well that's
all gone so a fossil fuel free and this
is far more efficient in terms of our
carbon footprint as well as our
reduction in fossil fuels The National
Trust Net Zero Target is 20 30. the
governments is 20 years later both say
heat pumps have a role in
decarbonization speak Hall shows they
are not for new builds I have a juice of
care to look after this special place
forever so by with our ability to
control the levels of heat and humidity
in a way we've never done before is just
one less pressure on looking after the
special place but in a cost of living
crisis Net Zero feels for some not now
that's why reducing consumption is an
important First Step as applicable in a
mansion house as somewhere smaller
the key thing it doesn't really matter
what size the property is or what the
activity the key thing is try and reduce
the amount of energy that you're using
in the first place at home in my
household be doing exactly the same
thing checking I've got that Loft
insulation have I got double blazing and
I even just draw the curtains to um you
know in the evening make sure we're
trying to keep as much heat inside as
possible and then where are you getting
your heat from
um and and can you get that from a more
sustainable um way
tradition meets technology
for a Net Zero future both must work
together Katrina Potosi Sky News in
Liverpool